well Johns Hopkins University in the
u.s. is tracking the outbreak based on
WH old figures and infection and was
released by the government's themselves
the big red circles over China and the
Virtua the viral epicenter Wuhan
indicate where most cases are I'd say
deja the major concentrations are in the
Middle East mainly Iran and Europe
chiefly Italy overall almost 100,000
people have caught the corona virus
fifty-five thousand or so have recovered
and three thousand three hundred have
died well let's go now to the Chinese
epicenter Wuhan which along with its
surrounding province remains in lockdown
joining us from there is raha to Lacan a
medical student who's been under
quarantine in an apartment since January
20 seconds thank you so much for
speaking to us here on al-jazeera
you've been under quarantine for it
looks like almost six weeks now what on
earth is like life like in Wuhan where
you are can you hear us rehearse
Oerlikon yeah I can hear you okay I was
just saying that the story in the news
programs appears to have moved on from
China but it's very easy to forget the
people like yourself are still under
quarantine in the city of Wuhan just
give us a sense what life is like for
you right now yeah it's true you've been
in quarantine for the last 40 to 45 days
and we requested our government from the
government of Pakistan to Kuwaitis we
have tried to reach out to our
government we have tried to reach out to
our embassy for evacuation but in
response we have got nothing
the response is almost zero from our
government our embassy and apart from
that the Chinese government itself is
doing more more I hope they will control
the situation very Sounion it's almost
decreasing very decreasing day by day
and the core analysis will be controlled
with sewing shovel I hope so
Chinese people they are doing their best
the Chinese : they are doing their best
but we have been disappointed from the
Pakistani : from the Pakistani embassy
and we got almost no response from them
for our evacuation I mean that must be
terrible January 22nd me sick for four
to six weeks that you've been left in
quarantine no help from your government
do you feel abandoned at all exactly
exactly
we the Chinese going instead of they are
doing to provide us all the basic
facilities they are trying their best to
provide all kind of food they are trying
their best to provide whatever they came
to became we are very happy from the
government of China from the Chinese
people from the school where you are
living they are trying their best but
all what we are doing is that at this
time is we go been in our room for the
last 40 to 45 days and it's not possible
for human being to stay in one place for
their long so definitely we are we have
been abandoned for the last 40 to 45
days and it's really a very mind blowing
almost on the students they are there
you've been kind of they have been in a
kind of strength they are
psychologically offset the going to
enter in the psychological problems and
so yes ready for all of us
well absolutely and you touch on that
there the fact that you're so isolated
and people are encouraged to stay in
their own rooms and yet people that were
social animals we need human contact
just give a third a sense of you woods
and how is that impacting on you and
your friends
exactly all of us almost we are 70 to 75
students living here in the same
building and none of us have been
infected so far hamdullah we all are
safe
no one will be infected none of us is
ahead by the coronavirus and you are
saying the same thing to our goal there
please we are not infected
you can keep us in a quarantine for one
quarantine and everyone we can stay for
a double quarantine we can go there and
we can stay there for quarantine and
nowadays the Iran it's same day getting
heated by the corona Vanzetti China has
been happy and they are giving the
Pakistani government is doing the same
thing with people the Pakistani people
living in Iran the Pakistani people dead
they are coming for dead are coming from
Iran the important in quarantine for 10
to 14 days
and after that they screened him and
India cleared the letting go and let
them go to Pakistan so we are saying the
same thing you can put us in a
quarantine and if we are clear if you
are not infected to feel you're healthy
you should let us go back to our home
you should let us go back to our country
but they are not doing the same okay
well roxeanne thank you so much for
sharing your story and your experience
and we do hope that you get the help you
need very soon thank you good you're
welcome thank you so much